hi everybody as you know I've been
talking about micro dosing psychedelics
as a medicine for about a year now I've
been at rege by this you know new
development because it has the potential
to become groundbreaking medicine we
don't know that yet so many companies
and initiatives are starting to do
research that actually started in the
early 60s was shut down because a lot of
the psychedelics became illegal but now
the promise of perhaps fixing huge
problems like drug addiction opioid
addiction alcoholism depression ad D all
of these metrics put into the basket of
maybe what micro dosing psychedelics
could help
we found companies that are merged one
of them is mind med now for full
disclosure and transparency I'm an
investor in mind man it's the one I've
chosen for a bunch of reasons we're
gonna find out today but I thought the
best thing to do on the eve of some
research that actually came out this is
probably the first in-depth research of
mine med since the company went public I
would get the CEO on J I ran and we
could talk to him a little bit about
what this company is going to be doing
over the next few years and what the
initiative of this whole industry is
going to be Jr welcome to the show
thanks for having me Kevin
let's talk big picture let's go to
30,000 feet and tell me what this whole
initiative is about let's talk about the
industry why you got involved what mine
mids doing versus the others let's start
there so my med was set up to develop
medicines that are based on psychedelics
we saw a great opportunity and a lot of
untapped value because these are
schedule 1 substances they're skip my
schedule 1 you mean they are illegal
drugs they're illegal right that's
correct yeah so they were made illegal
in 1970 and all research really stopped
on these substances but what I think is
intriguing is that these substances
actually started here I actually have
the original patent for LSD it was
started in in the 1930s and 1940s by a
modern psychedelic revolution really
started by a guy named Albert Hoffman
who was working at Sandoz laboratories
which is now part of Novartis the major
pharmaceutical group and that is where
a lot of research was being proposed
that LSD and other psychedelics should
be medicines and so what we're trying to
do really is complete that legacy now
what's involved in going through this
because you know I want to be clean and
on the record about this when I was
first approached by one of your board
members over a year ago to get involved
in mine MIT I said absolutely no way I
don't want anything to do with
recreational drugs I never got invested
in cannabis for that reason it's a
Schedule one narcotic still is federally
however I was assured that this work
you're going to be doing is going to be
the pursuit of medicine so walk me
through what stages have to occur when
you're dealing with a Schedule one
narcotic how do you get that to an
fda-approved drug what's the process so
the process is exists you can make a
medicine that is based on a Schedule one
substance there are there are many
examples out there um what we are
ultimately doing when we go through an
FDA process is proving the safety and
efficacy of a substance or molecule and
so in order to do that you need to have
very very highly pure a version of the
substance called GMP and so we've
actually produced we're producing that
for various substances that were working
on but in terms of how you actually do
this through the FDA process you have to
have clinical trials and in order to get
the exemptions to file what we call an
investigational new drug or an IND you
also need to get sign-off from the DEA
and other and other organizations
because these are scheduling substances
but it doesn't preclude anyone from from
doing a clinical trial to prove that
there's a therapeutic value of a
substance
now this originally this compound let's
just take LSD for example a psychedelic
that's well-known in society as a
psychedelic drug it got a very bad rap
in the early 60s obviously but that was
created in Switzerland was it not isn't
that the origination or found or
discovered or processed in Switzerland
that's right yeah I'm LSD was discovered
by Albert Hofmann who was one of the
most successful chemists
a place called Sandoz laboratories which
is now part of the pharmaceutical giant
Novartis and they were working on LSD
for therapeutic potential that's why it
was sent all around the world to
different psychiatrists one of which was
with Timothy Leary and ultimately what
happened was the the the medicines
weren't controlled and because of that
the 1960s really demonized these
substances for political reasons but
didn't really focus on the therapeutic
benefit that these you know LSD could
could have on society and and patients
and so that is what we are proving now
we need to take the data conduct
clinical trials and prove that these
substances actually can benefit people
and I think if we can do that in a
compelling manner to the FDA they will
eventually become medicines let's talk
about that I mean the anecdotal data
let's stay on LSD for a moment because
I'm an investor in many many companies
in Silicon Valley and in Boston and
Texas Florida you name it young
engineers and I and I'm not endorsing
this by any means but it's anecdotal
data have been micro dosing LSD or or
you know reportedly doing this and
getting some very interesting positive
outcomes about productivity and support
of a DD and reducing the symptoms of
that etc this is all anecdotal not
proven not legal so I don't endorse it
but it is intriguing to consistently
hear this buzz out there in the you know
the community of those that are using
this and it's almost like some kind of a
counterculture but it's not for
psychedelic reasons it's not for
tripping and and hallucinating it's for
helping them with their day-to-day
problems what Evans what evidence do we
have of that what have you heard about
it why is that making why is that a
constant buzz in the background of this
industry well you know I come from
Silicon Valley I was an early employee
at uber I went through the Y Combinator
program where you know companies like
Airbnb and Dropbox came out of and I can
tell you that micro dosing in Silicon
Valley is a very big trend and it's it's
an illegal trend but it is you know
vastly growing I'm
there's also many reddit groups out
there that you can you can view you know
people that are micro dosing LSD and
psilocybin for their benefits of
potential increased focus you know
changing their mood just overall mood
disorder that that's very interesting
compelling anecdotal evidence but the
issue Kevin is that it's anecdotal and
what mine met our company is trying to
do is say okay right there's all this
compelling anecdotal evidence now we
want to take it and prove the data works
and so we're actually doing the first
phase two trial from micro dosing of LSD
and we will be looking at it for adult
ADHD you know there are millions of
adults I was one of them my parents you
know brought me to the psychiatrist and
I was 13 years old and sent me out with
a bottle which is the equivalent of you
know a substance very close to two
methamphetamine you know so it's uh it's
a it's an industry that is huge ADHD but
it also is an industry where you have my
generation looking for alternatives to
the stimulant based medicines that we've
been on for most of our lives that have
terrible side effects and I think I'm
seeing a lot of crop promise in micro
dosing of LSD for that and I was sitting
you know in in Toronto sort of shortly
after you invested and and actually in
the same restaurant that we met in and I
was wearing my mind med t-shirt which I
like to wear everywhere and it says
psychedelic inspired medicines on the
front and the waitress comes up to me
and she goes what are you doing in
psychedelics and I said whoa hold on a
second is this I'm you know we do
everything's federally legal that that
we conduct is this a raid and she goes
no no I microdose LSD I've been on a I'm
sorry
ritalin since I was six years old and
I'm using it to get off of my Ritalin
and I found profound effects on my
ability to focus and think creatively
and so that's when I had the real aha
moment that you know this can be huge I
mean there are a lot of people affected
by
the ADHD and we can help them get off of
these stimulants now I read this
research today while I was on my bike in
the morning that's my routine is to read
research while I'm working out I think I
read this at 5:30 a.m. and I want to
talk to you about there's two trials
referenced in this research that you are
getting involved in the first let's
start with the first the the LSD trial
where is that taking place when is it
taking place what is the timeline
investors should think about in terms of
that research and what is the what is
the hopeful outcome in terms of just a
what is the scale or value of a drug
like that should you be successful in
turning into a medicine
yeah what's really interesting about
this phase 2 micro dosing of LSD for
adult ADHD is it's the first phase 2
trial to really look at micro dosing
there's been plenty of phase 1 trials
that you know have looked actually not
plenty there's about 3 which isn't which
is not much and in the context of
medicine but we're altima looking to
prove that there's a therapeutic benefit
of micro dosing LSD on a weekly regiment
in various doses that can help you focus
and help with the symptoms of ADHD we're
going to be beginning that in the fourth
quarter in Europe and we will be making
more announcements about enrollment and
and how of that trial is progressing but
really what we're looking for here is
the first data-driven efficacy signal
that micro dosing has a Arup utak
benefit and I think with that it
broadens what we can do in our micro
dosing division this is our first trial
of micro dosing of LSD I think we're
going to look at other potentials for
micro dosing that that that you know the
anecdotal evidence is extremely
compelling it's very rare that you go
into a drug trial where you know the
substance has been you know just in the
US I I heard that you know it
psychedelics have been in been in 30
million people right it's very rare as a
drug company that you know something is
not toxic like that that it's not
killing people that's you know part of
one of the biggest parts of
moving the safety of something and so we
just find that as an investment thesis
amazing because it's de-risk the
proposition significantly knowing that
you know we're not gonna kill people
that we put the substance into the
research also makes reference to a
compound or molecule called eighteen MC
talk to us about that what is it what
are the trials on that what is the
hopeful outcome of that medicine well
that eighteen MC is dealing with the
opioid crisis I mean we have a huge
problem in the United States right now
the opioid crisis cost the country five
hundred billion dollars a year there's
11 million people misusing opioids this
is having very bad impact on society not
to mention that you know now with kovat
nineteen and people in isolation the
rates of addiction are going to
skyrocket when this whole thing shakes
out I mean there is there's compelling
data around rat models that were
isolated and and they were looked at
versus rats that were not in isolation
and the rats in isolation increase the
consumption of addictive substances by
1900 so you can only imagine what the
great lockdown is doing to our mental
health and addiction right now and so
what 18 M C is going to do and and and
continues with our we will be starting
our Phase two trial in 18m C in the
fourth quarter is how do we completely
relook at how we treat addiction
addiction right now it's like it's being
treated with a substance for opioid
addiction that is like a nicotine patch
it's something called suboxone or
methadone which you may have heard of
it's as addictive as heroin and it's not
addressing the underlying reason of
addiction which is something in our
brain called dopamine dopamine
ultimately when you get high or when you
have a drink
that's a dopamine rush and that is the
underlying cause of addiction there's a
lot of research out there the national
inch
drug abuse Nora Volkov has been
pioneering this research 18 MC have
received 6.8 million dollars from the
National Institute on Drug Abuse and so
we're gonna be pushing this research
forward getting a Phase two and
ultimately what we want to do is create
the antibiotic of addiction we don't
want to put people on a pill a day for
the rest of their lives I think that's
vastly different than most
pharmaceutical companies we actually
want to solve the problem
Jerr you recently took this company
public and yet it has no revenue it's an
early-stage company I remember when I
was invited to invest in it in a private
placement I looked at it as a binary
outcome in other words either you're
gonna prove the effectiveness of one of
these or multiple compounds as medicines
real medicines or this thing is going to
zero how am I is an investor so in other
words either it's a fantastic outcome
because the problems you're trying to
solve are multi billion dollar markets
or it's a zero how am I is an investor
to figure out as this now is training
publicly what is my net worth how would
I know how can I even guess is there
anything you can give me as guidance to
value this company well what else say is
this binary outcomes definitely that's
drug development right you have to
invest millions into trials to prove
that they work what's compelling about
mine med right now is we're assembling a
portfolio of many of these different
psychedelics inspired medicines and
there might be a few binary outcomes one
of them might be a zero one of them
might be you know really really big so
when when we look at the space in drug
development and and my our chief
scientific officer and our chief medical
officer we had a conversation a couple
weeks ago and they said look when we've
been developing drugs for 30 years we've
never seen anecdotal evidence like this
going into a trial knowing something
might actually work a lot of times it's
really just a gamble and so I think you
know we have there's definitely a DRS
proposition in the broader psychedelic
space and making these into medicines
when you think about valuing the company
well you know we're building a
completely new asset class this is not
you know a traditional medicine I mean
these are going to be a whole new
industry that's sprouting up so I think
if you want to value the company is well
if you're building a new business
segment how big can that company
eventually get if it becomes the leader
in the field and we are one of the
leaders in this field there's only
really three companies out there that
are doing this Peter teal backed one
that just raised 80 million dollars
called compass pathways and then there's
a company like us mine med which is
public already and is accessible to all
investors and I think these are going to
become the leading companies in the
space and you know we're fortunate to
get smart guys like you to see that
early and and and help us build a very
very big company over the long term so
the the the process now of both of these
trials are these the two you're focused
on are there more what else can you what
what other markets potentially can this
industry and obviously mine man is where
I'm putting my bet and I'd like to
actually get you on the record on this
one because many institutional investors
share my my concerns I'm gonna use that
word that that we don't want to invest
in in companies and the example was the
the cannabis companies that could never
give us a path to invest in medicine
alone we always had to get involved in
the tremendous controversy of
recreational use of marijuana which I
have no interest in backing and I don't
want to be caught up in that controversy
I'm not pro or con I just don't want to
invest in something that doesn't have a
clear path to a medicine and it's just
going to be involved in all this the
issues that each state has to go through
in the case of of this industry and you
know in the in the case of mine med you
have assured investors like me because
I'm not the only one that has this
concern particularly institutional
investors that the pursuit this company
has mine med specifically will never be
into recreational use of psychedelics go
on the record jr. yes sir
well I know I know that but I want to
hear what you say to a water a broader
base of institutional investors who are
gonna see this what is that what what is
the Mandate of the company so my men
will never touch recreational
psychedelics we have no intention and
getting involved in the politics of that
I think that can get very very messy
what we're focused on is helping
patients and the way to help patients
with with lots of diseases here in the
United States mental illnesses is to do
that through the FDA pathway there's a
clear way to do that that's how every
single medicine that has become approved
has gone through the FDA why reinvent
the wheel there you know I think this is
a really important thing and and by the
way you're not the only guy that I gave
the handshake on to this there's some
pretty big funds in New York that came
into the pre public round that wanted
the same handshake because they can't be
seen to investing into inter
recreational so you know schedule one
narcotics I mean that's just it's not
possible for them for their funds and so
that's why they were able to invest into
us um what I will say is we need to
really focus on why we are doing this
what are the outcomes let's not focus on
the substances let's focus on the
potential outcomes for some really sick
people out there there are 40 million
Americans that have anxiety there are 20
million plus suffering from substance
abuse disorders these are big big
problems and so to answer your question
a little bit further what else we'll be
looking at besides our opioid addiction
focused trial and our adult ADHD with
LSD trial I'm very interested in anxiety
we are we acquired a Phase two trial
from the University Hospital Basel and
dr. Matthias Lee who's the leading
researcher in the LSD space and has been
for a number of years and that will have
some potential readouts in in the
not-too-distant future on that Phase two
trial and I think that when we look at
that trial we're going to be very
compelled to go into the anxiety space
and created a whole new drug program
around anxiety and we're going to need
it because
kovat 19 I mean I was I was in the
pharmacy the other day just picking up a
prescription and the woman in front of
me was the pharmacist was talking to her
and she says he said well I know this is
you know your first time getting xanax
do you understand what it's worth and
she goes yeah I was watching CNN and my
doctor said that I probably you know
needed an anti-anxiety medication so
that's why I got this you know that's a
big big problem that's gonna come out of
here and I think the next you know you
know and I'm gonna come probably come
back here in a year or two and we're
gonna be talking about this annex crisis
so we need to focus on disruptive
technologies and solutions to to mental
health that is what we are trying to
achieve as a company finally if I'm an
investor in mind med and I am what
should I be looking for in terms of just
scheduling or milestones in the road
over the next year what what is it that
you're trying to achieve that I should
say that is a good milestone to achieve
as an investor I'd care about just map
me out the next 12 months what matters
well look I think it's very important to
start phase through trials and so we'll
be we'll be starting phase two trials
very soon on to drug trials in addition
there is a lot of IP that we can
generate out of this acquisition that
we've done with the University Hospital
Basel I look forward to further IP
filings around what we're working on
there and then some new ideas that might
be phase one trials but could be new
forms of using psychedelics so those are
the milestones you want to look for
because trust me Big Pharma is
interested in this space they've really
stayed in the sidelines to date there
was one company Johnson & Johnson who
was who was working on s ketamine which
got approved which is a very similar to
psychedelic experience and that was
approved in q2 2019 they are going in by
2024 consensus estimates say one point
four billion dollars a year in revenue
these are big markets that's up for
treatment-resistant depression it's true
it's not it's unfortunate they're big
markets I mean solving for opioid
action which has touched so many
families in America in a very bad way or
even alcoholism or you know a DD or
addiction or any of these things if any
of these drugs work then my investment
thesis will have been hopefully proven
because every market you're looking at
as an industry is huge I don't see small
vertical drugs here I see big big big
problems that are costing society
billions of dollars and they say huge
opportunities should at work it's just I
don't know yet that's why I asked about
milestone and time tables and look I've
got to tell you I wish you the best of
luck obviously as an investor but I
think you know the company has a bit of
a moral and social mission to I mean to
solve something so miserable as opiate
addiction or even alcoholism which has
touched so many families if there was a
way to solve for that it would be an
amazing outcome and a financially
rewarding one for the company investors
and the people that don't have to suffer
from that misery so Jay I really wish
you the best of luck we'll be checking
in from time to time obviously there's a
lot of interest in this space and a lot
of controversy no question about it
you're messing with something that you
know came out of the past in the 60s
with a pretty bad connotation on it and
now you want us all to believe it's a
medicine
I think that's intriguing well thank you
and and we do have a mission at my med I
mean this is really about how do we help
patients that are having problems and so
these are big societal problems and I
think if we can if we can make a dent
into them we're gonna have a better
country in a better society and I'll
leave you with this the inventor of LSD
albert hofmann he said I hope that one
day my problem child will become my
wonder child and I can't think of
anybody else better to help us with that
than mr. wonderful thank you so much the
company is mine mad it's an intriguing
participant in this industry that looks
to take formally illegal scheduled
schedule one drugs remain illegal in the
70s like LSD and other molecules and
turn them into medicines to solve some
of society's biggest problems
like opioid addiction alcoholism ETD you
name it
problems of the mind hence mine med
anyways gr thank you so much for your
time today we'll be checking in again
take care everybody you can go online
and learn a lot more about this industry
because people are intrigued take care
everybody stay safe
you